how do you write off jewelry so like
this right here like well one gold is an
investment it's a mineral true so it can
go up in value and it has universal
trade value true so
in the simplest term
it's like the the government is like if
you're going to invest in an asset
whether it's property or there's a jury
then you can write that off because
you're basically saying this is a future
investment for me to be able to do
something with it um and as far as
dependent it has my my actual brand on
there i'm the owner of the company i'm
on the paperwork so i'm able to say this
is a costume fee or promotional fee for
my company and just be able to write it
off at the end of the year rather than
me spending upfront cash so let's say
technically my my tax bill at the end of
the year was thirty thousand
if i spend fifteen thousand on this
chain i only gotta spend i only gotta
pay fifteen thousand of that back to the
government and the other fifteen
thousand goes down is a write-off
through jury
costume expense all that